[Music]
hello I'm Jenny direct oh this is the
daily Denny and it's Thursday which
means we're live guys like live live
like right now forgive me in advance
because I am a little under the weather
hence my tea I feel like Wendy Williams
well it's only fitting because you know
I know those Prince William and Kate up
on this mug but we're here to talk about
Prince Harry
and Megan Marco we are officially can
you believe it just one month away from
the Royal Wedding and in 30 days Prince
Harry will Wed Megan Marco and what will
be a global affair I can't tell but you
guys let me know are you as excited as I
am it seems plenty of Americans like me
are so into it because Harry found him a
nice woman from across the pond let me
know in the comments section we'll be
getting them to this iPad right here in
any case there is a lot of excitement
around the world leading up to Prince
Harry and Megan Markel's big royal day
which is why I called on our royal
expert lauren zima to spill the royalty
cheerio yes Prince Harry and Megan
Merkel's wedding is on Saturday May 19th
and you want to be in the know but we
know that you are busy so I'm here to
help here's everything you need to know
will in Kate's wedding a few years ago
was a global event millions watched and
if you want to watch Harry and Megan's
wedding live be aware of time zones the
wedding is at Windsor Castle in Windsor
England the ceremony starts at 12 p.m.
local time England will be in the time
zone BST which is British summer time
for example it's 8 hours ahead of Los
Angeles but luckily I will actually be
there bringing you updates from the
ground like after the wedding I'll be
all over the carriage procession what's
that well at 1 p.m. local time the
newlyweds will literally get in a
carriage and trot around the town so all
the well-wishers and fans can say hello
hello Harry and Megan also get to
celebrate privately though first with a
big reception for the hundreds of guests
then with
and smaller one thrown by Harry's dad
Prince Charles it's just for close
friends and family okay that one's the
party but I'll try to sneak it ready to
I won't get in in terms of guests we can
only guess invitations have gone out and
we're expecting celebrities like the
Spice Girls are you gonna get a chance
to do it again at the wedding and
Megan's co-stars from her hit show suits
now what will you get them as a royal
cotton couple look if you go to the
wedding or not will you send like a
toaster we do know we likely won't see
world leaders there Harry is friendly
with the Obamas but the palace has said
not to expect political leaders are you
diverse accent and a source tells et
this is different than Prince William's
wedding why well William will be King
one day his brother Harry won't
so Harry's wedding is not as much of an
estate event but isn't it more fun to
talk about colors and cake and stuff
guys I have all that info over on
spilling the royalty on et's YouTube
channel check it out we have so much
insider sourcing on this wedding we are
all over it which is why we call on you
Lawrence so thank you so so very very
much all right are you guys excited to
see this wedding or is it just me I
don't know about you but I think there
is something to be said about the fact
that Harry is marrying an American
biracial actress not to mention she is
beautiful regal philanthropic and I'm
getting like some serious Princess Diana
vibes
the couple is shaking up the monarchy
and I am here for it in fact et has
learned Megan wants to incorporate a few
American traditions into the wedding a
source tells et Harry has deferred to
his bride to be on the plans but she
knows there are royal tradition to
consider but wants to add some special
touches that would reflect her and
Harry's tastes our source also says that
Megan has been repping the Royals more
and more at a number of official events
which is a sign of how confident they
are in her according to the source Megan
is not afraid to express her views and
they see her as a real asset
and to that I say we have our very own
American princess y'all I love that you
know we learned from Andrew Morton the
author who wrote an unauthorized book
about Harry and Megan's relationship
that Harry actually cut YouTube clips of
Megan's acting and her TV show suits to
show the Queen who he was marrying can
you guys imagine pitching the Queen with
the clip real this is what I want to
marry grandmom just go right here I love
her and she's a great actress
all right well as fate would have it
making its character on suits is also
getting married before she's a royal
bride here's a look at Megan's TV I Do's
ready for this I can't believe it
[Music]
I wanted to marry you from the second I
met you you are the husband I've always
wanted
I love you
and I always will
you guys I just love weddings
you know what I'm not alone reading for
facebook says you can barely wait for
the wedding I'm so excited for both of
them
me too Rita me too all right now
speaking of weddings I couldn't leave
you guys without talking about some
other exciting marriage news Michelle
Williams of Destiny's Child is engaged
Michelle told people all about it and
apparently she's been secretly engaged
to pastor Chad Johnson for nearly a
month the two have been dating for a
year so could we expect beyoncé and
Kelly to be bridesmaids on the big day
while Michelle told the lady gang
podcast they are definitely on that list
but she's still figuring out if she even
wants a wedding party so we shall see
meanwhile American royalty and
Michelle's pals of course Beyonce and
jay-z were spotted Tuesday night at John
and Vinny's Italian restaurant in LA and
join a little post Coachella date night
and I witnessed lzt they looked so happy
to be out chatting smiling at each other
a lot and even at one point giving each
other a playful fist bump and if you
want to know what they were noshing on
well apparently they ordered a pizza and
Beyonce sit on some wine so I guess that
vegan diet is over beat but you earned
it let's just call it a solid recharge
before she hits the Coachella stage
again for weekend - I'll be there you
guys but not before another day lead any
tomorrow so make sure you guys check it
out it is new music Friday so make sure
you guys are subscribed or et's et's
youtube channel following us on Facebook
but before I go I see more comments
coming in Rita saying the marna monarch
needed a little shake-up way from
YouTube said where'd you get that Cup
you know what we have connections way we
have connections amber from Facebook she
loves Megan in suits hard to believe it
has or hers is her last season in the
show
Junaid from YouTube says love you
channel love your channel thank you so
much Junaid
Oh guys that's all the tea I have for
today again make sure you guys come back
tomorrow for new music Friday plus we
have Prince's unreleased recording of
nothing compares to you from 1984 so
really special episode and I'll see you
guys tomorrow I'm gonna go take a nap
[Music]